les vins sages de la commission stasi
sont allés bien au delà des questions du
port du voile à l'école on peut dire que
pour la première fois depuis 1905
c'est un véritable état des lieux de la
laïcité qui a pu être dressé en france
la laïcité est un principe
constitutionnel comme nous le rappelle
stéphanie perez la laïcité ou l'histoire
d'une exception française
un principe constitutionnel fondateur de
la république dont on comprend toute la
singularité des l'étude de son
étymologie heico c'est l'adjectif de la
hausse et la hausse servir le peuple
c'est à dire que laïc c'est ce qui
s'oppose acteurs écosse c'est à dire les
gens savants les gens qui savent écrire
les gens qui ont une fonction religieuse
en fait donc le laïc et celui qui n'est
pas impliquée dans la vie religieuse la
laïcité impliquent donc la séparation
des églises et de l'état
c'est la loi de 1905 chacun est libre de
choisir sa religion l'église ne doit
exercer aucun pouvoir politique
l'état aucun contrôle dans le domaine
religieux aucun financement du culte
l'état qui doit être impartial et les
représentants de la fonction publique
neutre au coeur de ce dispositif
républicain l'école elle est censée
forger des citoyens libres donc
responsables à partir de 1880 jules
ferry la rend obligatoire gratuite
laïque et ils suppriment l'instruction
religieuse puis les enseignants
religieux
l'école c'est le lieu où se forme la
conscience humaine dans sa liberté et la
question est de savoir si l'école est là
pour conditionner les enfants un message
particulier ou si elle est là pour
construire en eux l'autonomie et la
capacité de ne dépendre que de soi
l'église catholique mettra 20 ans a
accepté que la religion ne relève plus
que du seul domaine privé aujourd'hui le
concept laïque et de nouveaux objets de
débats mais parce que la société
française de 2003 affichent une plus
grande
des religieuses que celle de 1905
[Musique]